[Music]
let's go to nikki in
denver colorado
what's up nikki
thanks for taking my call dr john thanks
for calling how in the world are you
i'm doing all right very cool so what's
up
um
so about three and a half years ago uh
my dad committed suicide
lately over
um i would say maybe the last year
i've dealt with a lot of
guilt around not being able to help my
dad um
when i thought he was struggling yeah
and my question is
how can i
sorry oh you're good take your time
how do i pull myself out of those
spirals that i get myself into of
feeling guilty and
responsible for not being able to help
my dad
i'm so sorry
that's hard
tell me about your dad tell me about him
growing up
um
he was funny
yeah he
was a really fun dad he was in law
enforcement so
you know his job was hard and
there were a lot of times that were hard
growing up but um
i love my dad i love my dad
and
the last few years of our relationship
were really strained because
he was pretty sick
and
um
so that was hard but
as a kid i loved i loved my dad yeah
what about your mom what role did she
play in your childhood
um my mom was also great both both of my
parents were around growing up um
my mom was kind of my spiritual anchor
growing up
and she was kind of the one that run ran
the household and
um
you know as a teenager i had a pretty
stringent relationship with my mom but
now dave she's my best friend and i i
love my mom a lot that's cool you've
been my rock through a lot so what
happened four five six years ago you
said you saw your dad got sick and you
saw
a shift in his personality tell me about
that
um
so
when i was a kid my dad had an accident
and he
ended up on
pain medication um
to help manage the pain from this
accident
and
um
i didn't know it until much later in my
life but
he became really dependent on pain
medication was that when you were a kid
too
that was when i was a kid but a lot of
the issues from it didn't manifest until
at least not from what i could tell
until i was
a teenager okay
and then over time it just got worse and
worse and then a few years ago what was
the circumstances around him taking his
taking his life
um
he
he just struggled with
not only physical pain but
just emotional and mental health yeah um
being in law enforcement my dad was not
one to reach out for help right um
it was just a stigma that i was very
aware of growing up
you know
he
felt that
asking for help showed weakness and
even when he really needed it
i don't think he knew how to ask or even
accept help that's right and i've spent
my life around police officers and
you're exactly right that's one of the
biggest challenges
that that community faces is being able
to raise your hand and say hey i'm i'm
drowning here yeah i need some help yeah
how old are you
uh i'm 27 27 and you have a family you
buy you live by yourself you get little
kids like tell me where you are in life
i i am single as the day i was born
i'm i uh live by myself um my mom and my
younger brother still live close but um
yeah i live out on my own now and
i'm
doing well for the most part i have a
good job i am rooted in a good church
and i so what does this debilitation
feel like
when you start thinking about it walk me
through some of the thoughts that pop
into your head
it almost feels like panic sometimes
yeah um i've gone through a lot of my
own health journeys over the last couple
years just
trying to get my own
physical and mental health in a good
place
not that it's ever been super bad but
you know i've always wanted to do better
for myself and
i think as i learn more about how to
keep myself well
i
think about the things that i could have
done for my dad to try to help him be
well
um
and so i just it gets to a place where
i end up sitting in my guilt
for
sometimes a couple days
um
so
let me
you and i could sit down for a couple of
hours and
really dig into some stuff and so i'm
gonna take a few of the things you said
and do a flyby here
um
and i may be wrong on a few things
but i've sat with a number of folks in
your situation so tell me if i'm right
okay and if i'm wrong please call me out
okay but when you grow up in the home of
someone who's fun
and hilarious and they work a traumatic
job and
they're an addict
for a young
child the memories can be about the
silliness and the fun sometimes the
volatility like that occasional burst of
anger and you're like whoa
but what your brain and your heart
detect is that detachment
your brain and your heart
and this is a physiological thing this
isn't some woo emotional thing
it knows that your dad is
six klonopin into an evening
or five oxy's into an evening
it knows that he you are in the presence
of your father and he's not there
because he's high
your little kid brain sees him and sees
that smile that fake half half sleepy
smile that is silly and come on up and
let's cuddle
but your brain knows we're disconnected
and for the child of an addict this is
with alcohol this is with any number of
things
this is with parents who nowadays just
are so busy with work they're just
scrolling on their phones 24 7 365 and
their kid is staring at them and they're
talking to them but they know they're
not present
and your
brain will literally try to solve that
connection forever
forever
because
your body and your brain knows that guy
loves me he says he loves me he's here
but i can feel there's a
gulf between us it must be my fault and
that's you hear me say all the time
that's what five-year-olds and
seven-year-olds they try to solve that
disconnection problem especially with
with parents who have traumatic jobs
especially with parents who struggle
with mental health issues especially
with parents who struggle with
addiction and now you fast forward
to one of the most tragic things
which is a father who loves his daughter
and got to a place in his heart and his
head that said i don't want to die
but i need this to stop
and
i think my daughter's life will be
better with me not here
and that math doesn't make sense to you
because you know that's not true but it
made sense in his head and in his heart
and here's what your sweet brain and
heart is still trying to do
number one it's still trying to bridge
that gap
you're still trying to solve him
and number two the even scarier thing is
our brains solve for control
that's what anxiety is that's what all
that depression is is our brain solving
for control
and you can't control this
and so what it will do it will it will
reach back and try to say well we should
have
and really what that is it's a
protective mechanism to say if it ever
happens again then
if i ever love recklessly and deeply
again i will make sure that
and exhale
you can't and i'm so sorry because it
feels so powerless right
yeah
and
you may have heard me say this before we
spend so much energy and this isn't just
you this is all of us we spend so much
energy with a pen in our hand
trying to go back and edit sentences
of our lives that have already been
written with periods at the end of the
sentence and you can't edit them
the only thing on earth we can do is
write a new one right
right
my guess is did you go to your dad's
funeral
so
we didn't have a traditional funeral for
him okay um
dad always wanted to be cremated so we
cremated him as all cops do it's the
weirdest thing man
i don't understand i don't either every
cop i know is like no just cremate me
we'll move on
like golly
like we want to do more for you than
that but you know i mean we wanted to
honor what he had always told us because
i mean as a cops kid you grow up with
the realization that you know at any
point in time something could happen
every day could be the day
exactly it was a conversation that was
very open in our house and um so we we
cremated him and
um we had some family and we
we um spread his ashes uh
in one of his favorite spots where we
grew up
so we didn't really have a traditional
funeral but you know we did do something
okay
does your mom still miss him
i think she does um
they had a really
strange relationship
especially in the last five or six years
but my dad was
yeah
um so the last thing i'll tell you is
this and then i'll walk you through a
couple things you can do
um
when i've
worked with young people
and you're unfortunately you're still a
young person because i'm old now when
i've worked with young people
there's this lingering thing in the back
of their head that says could this
happen to me
could i get to a place where things were
so cloudy and so gray
that i could do this
and that's a really scary thing have you
ever been there
you know good
i want you to stay committed to
you getting well which is really
extraordinary that you've branched out
to do that
um stay committed to that journey okay
um
so in all honesty my guess is
you haven't let him go yet
you did the funeral that he wanted
and you are still have a little girl in
you trying to solve his love
and trying to make sure he's okay
because that was your job that's a lot
of kid's job when their parents are
addicts and their parents are struggling
with mental health issues it's to make
sure they're okay
and there's a part of your heart and
mind that thinks you failed
and i need you to hear you did not fail
you didn't you loved that man and that
man loved you
and as you said it you said it's so
great he was sick and he died by suicide
and
when you let him go
the greatest gift you can give your old
man is to go live fully and love
correctlessly
and to be the little girl
and grow up into the extraordinary woman
i know you are
um and live
live
live
practically speaking i know it sounds so
easy you're like cool man but sometimes
i wake up on tuesdays and i can't
breathe right
yeah
like all these little cliche things
some of this is gonna be and again i
feel like i'm a broken record sometimes
um i just have seen this be so cathartic
in my personal life but in so many other
folks
is
whether you keep a journal
if i'm you here's what i do and i've
said this recently i would go over pay
and you may have already done this i'd
go over pay for a fancy pants leather
journal
and it would just be letters to dad
and when you wake up in the morning and
you can't breathe i'd write him a note
write him a letter
and when you are having a good coming up
on a birthday that you wish you were
there or you meet some somebody that
you're attracted to and you want to talk
to him about it write it down
and what you're going to do is you're
going to begin your brain will begin to
recognize we're safe we're here
and it will stop sounding all the alarms
as though there's a still present
emergency
because there's not but your brain's
still acting like it is yeah i also want
you to
spend four or five
weeks
maybe once a week
i want you to write a letter to
little nikki
i did this recently and it was really
profound i wrote some letters to john as
a kid 14 year old john seven-year-old
john
and i let john know that he's a good kid
and it wasn't his job to fill in the
blank xyz
and yay that was a mean thing that he
said and i was nine right
there was just some letting me off the
hook and i want you to write young nicki
some stories some letters
and let her know that she did the best
she could
she's a kid
she deserved better and she
was loved by her mom and her dad and she
just grew up in a chaotic situation
i really want you to stay connected to
a counselor during this tough season
at some point when you're writing
letters to your dad you're going to get
really really angry have you been there
yet
a few times good
i want you to know that's not
dishonoring of him
okay it's okay to be really really angry
and when you
um have your first little baby or you
get your first big promotion you say i
don't have any kids i'm just gonna go be
a rock star what
he should have been there and he's not
yeah and so it's okay to be angry and
it's okay to grieve that it's okay to be
really really sad about that
yeah and give yourself permission to
slowly open the shades back up and then
here's the last thing
laughter enjoy
and dating and
christmases and new presents and jumping
up and down and screaming because you're
excited about something
is not a dishonoring of your dad
and there's those moments when you feel
joy and then you feel like you're not
supposed to have joy because this
happened is that right
uh sometimes you know
yeah you deserve joy and laughter and
happiness
and when the grief waves come you
breathe and you go man i miss him
and you grab that little journal and you
say dad i miss you i wish you were here
today
but i'm living like i'm living i'm
living like a wild lady just like you
trained me except i'm driving the speed
limit dad i am good grief
and
i'm a cops kid too so i get it um
and
i'm doing all the thing right but i miss
you
and then what you're gonna find is that
grief that wave it's gonna feel like an
ocean it's gonna come over you and it
will go from lasting all morning
lasting three days
to lasting
30 minutes
to lasting five minutes
and then you're going to come up with a
series of practices whether it's walking
whether it's texting somebody that you
love whether it is writing a quick note
whether it's just looking up in the sky
you're going to come up with a quick
series of things and over the next six
months year two years these cycles will
happen faster and faster
and it's hard and i'm so sorry that you
went through this but i need you to let
little nikki go
i need to let grown up nikki go
and i need you to live
live live that's the best way to honor
your dad
and if you're a police officer out there
if you love a police officer if you love
a fireman if you love somebody military
if you love somebody who
is um
in a marginalized population is
routinely not safe routinely having to
go to places where they are um under
pressure
i need you
to
go get the help that you need
i need you to grab their face and look
them in the eye with both hands and say
i love you and i need you to call
somebody
the last couple years has been really
really hard when a lot of different
people
and i don't like getting phone calls
from buddies who say so and so passed
away whipped by suicide and their police
officers and firemen and military folks
and the police officers that i still
work with and talk to and they are
struggling
that members of my community that are on
the margins are struggling please get
the help you need
thank you so so much nikki for your
honesty and for openness
and healings around the corner